la bataille de Kiev a été lancé des tirs
sont entendus depuis hier maintenant
dans la capitale les les sonnettes
d'alarme retentissent les sirènes
d'alarme retentissent depuis plusieurs
heures maintenant je vais me tourner
vers vous à présent Thomas Edou bonjour
Thomas vous faites partie des
observateurs à FRANCE 24 vous regardez
les vidéos vous les disséquer
qu'avez-vous vu d'abord ce matin à Kiev
qu'est-ce qu'il se passe et bien il
existe tout d'abord cette vidéo qui a
été filmée dans le quartier de boulons
de ski à 8 km de la place Maidan dans le
centre de Kiev on peut entendre sur
cette vidéo des échanges de tirs entre
les troupes russes et les soldats
Ukrainiens on ne sait pas exactement qui
sont aussi soldat russe certains parlent
de saboteur en revanche hier un assaut a
eu lieu au nord-est nord-ouest de la
ville sur l'aéroport international
Antonov nous avons suivi cette asseau
héliportée quasiment en temps réel avec
les images disponibles nous avons
géolocalisé et vérifier donc
cette vidéo sur cette première vidéo qui
a été filmée tout près du fleuve nièpre
à l'est de l'aéroport on peut voir une
formation d'hélicoptère de transport
russe à un moment donné on peut voir
qu'un missile infrarouge est tiré en
leur direction par l'armée ukrainienne
et pour se défendre les aviateurs l'arc
des leurres pour tromper le missile donc
dans cette vidéo il vole en direction de
l'aéroport il existe aussi deux autres
vidéos que nous avons authentifié sur
l'une d'entre elles on peut voir la
formation des hélicoptés Russes voler en
direction de l'aéroport avec des panages
de fumée en arrière-plan les autorités
ukrainiennes ont indiqué avoir détecté
34 hélicoptères russes pendant l'attaque
et en ont abattu trois d'entre eux une
équipe de CNN a pu filmer les soldats
russes des troupes aéroportés à l'entrée
de l'aéroport mais les autorités
ukrainiennes ont finalement annoncé
avoir contre-attaqué puis repris
l'aéroport mais impossible de le
confirmer avec certitude alors on
commence à voir donc des troupes russes
sur le sol
ukrainien ça c'est sûr elles sont bien
avancées sur le territoire comment
pouvons-nous
distinguer les soldats Ukrainiens
justement des soldats russes alors à
première vue c'est pas très évident ils
ont pas pratiquement le même matériel et
même le camouflage se ressemblent à vrai
dire mais nous avons authentifié deux
vidéos qui ont été tournées à caroufka
sur un barrage au nord de la Crimée en
territoire
ukrainien un homme a filmé les troupes
russes à cet endroit à 60 km au nord de
la Crimée en territoire ukrainien il dit
qu'il n'y a pas de combat et que les
Russes l'ont autorisé à filmer il y a
aussi il y a aussi filmé un autre convoi
sur le même pont on peut voir des
véhicules des camions blindés des
transports de troupes c'est intéressant
car sur ces camions là on peut voir un
signe Z qui est bien distinctif c'est
une marque d'identification que l'on a
vu sur de très nombreux véhicules russes
en Ukraine c'est un style distinctif qui
leur permet de s'identifier entre eux et
autre chose les soldats russes portent
des brassards blancs à l'épaule c'est
brassard blanc nous avons nous avons vu
à plusieurs reprises y compris sur les
images de ciennen à l'entrée de
l'aéroport merci beaucoup